OPPONENTS.
AWAY WE GO HERE ON "HOCKEY NIGHT
IN CANADA."
NET, AND JUST LIKE THAT IT'S
1-NOTHING MINNESOTA.NNESOTA, AN
DO IT.
THEY JUST GET PUCKS TO NET.
THEY'VE GOT GOOD TRAFFIC, GOOD
NET
AND THE CALGARY FLAMES HAVE
AS SOON AS HE RECOGNIZED THE
HOLE, HE WAS AT THE TOP AND HE
TO LINDHOLM AND OVER TOYING TO .
NOT ABLE TO DO SO.HE SCORES!
MATTHEW BOLDY IN THE DEFENSIVE
ZONE,E,
HERE'S A CHANCE, BOLDY COMING
IN.
A BIG SAVE FROM MARKSTROM, AND A
SECONON
THAT'S HISH SCREEN FOR THE
FLAMES.
THERE YOU [INDISCERNIBLE].
[ Crowd Noise ] ERIKSSON EK TIP
STNG
TO GET POSSESSION, FOLIGNO
SHOOTS, AND WHAT
HE GOES FAR DOWN,OOK AT THE NET
LIKE THAT NICE JOB, GOOD
HAND-EYE TH LOTS OF
TIME AND SPACE, AND HE TAKES
ADVANTA
THE OPTIONS THERE FOR FIRST OF
HOME-AND-HOME, SO IT'S GOING TO
BE A FUNGAUDREAU FLIP PASS, AND
THERE'S NO GOALIE THIS TIME, SO
IT'S A LITTLE EASIER